there are drops 18.
depending on where you live getting the
vaccine means the chance at a check
like this that's right you could win 1
million
how about a chance to win a million
dollars the winner each wednesday will
receive
1 million dollars faced with falling
vaccination rates
states across the u.s are rolling out
incentives to get residents to roll up
their sleeves
are we ready but are these offers
working and are they worth the cost
stay safe ohio we needed to just shake
things up we need to bring some
excitement
and i felt that a million dollars
would bring excitement what a night it
is for you
lotteries like this one in ohio are part
of a ballooning list of vaccine
incentives that
has included free doughnuts free beer
fishing licenses baseball tickets a lap
around talladega super speedway
and we're gonna give five custom hunting
rifles
and five custom hunting shotguns away
many of these freebies and lotteries
started popping up last month
as the rate of vaccination in the u.s
slumped to about half of what it was at
its peak in april
it's not surprising that we've reached a
point where the supply of vaccines far
exceeds demand and it's time to start
getting creative about how to get some
of the stragglers over the finish line
but
at the same time we have to be very
clear-eyed about what these incentives
can
and can't do it hey how are you when
ohio governor mike dewine announced the
vaccine million lottery on may 12th
it was the first of its kind offering
adults a chance to win one of five one
million dollar prizes and teens a chance
to win one of five full-ride
scholarships
we were going down down down
and we couldn't break it no matter what
we did
so we didn't know what else to do so we
came up with this idea
you know having no guarantee that it
would work experts like dr
emily largent who researches how
incentives are used in medical studies
say lotteries won't motivate everyone
this is not a cure-all this is
something fun makes sense to try but we
shouldn't
count on this as being the uh the magic
bullet
recent polling shows about 12 percent of
americans still plan to wait and see
before getting the vaccine
of those only a small number said they
would be motivated to do so by
guaranteed incentives like 100
from their state or free tickets to a
sporting event or concert
these offers and lotteries may even
trigger the opposite response
in some instances offering large amounts
of money to do something that people
perceive
as risky or burdensome to make them feel
like it's even riskier
or more burdensome than it actually is
some lawmakers call these cash offers a
bribe
but dr largent says she's not worried
about these incentives taking away an
individual's choice
the bigger concerns really are that they
can distract from all the work that
needs to be going into trying to
promote vaccination in the community
that includes providing further
education and access to vaccines
the lottery she says should only be part
of a broader toolkit to promote
vaccination
but if these incentives are the right
use of money is heavily debated
in ohio's case the 5 million lottery was
pulled from federal coronavirus relief
funds
i knew at the time that we announced it
people were going to say dewine is crazy
they were going to say that's a waste of
money but the real waste is for people
to continue to die
ohio resident jessica nagy who got her
shot before the lottery announcement
says the money was well spent could have
been spent on you know advertising or
marketing to educate people on the
vaccine
but i mean how effective would that
really be when anybody can get on
facebook or social media and say
anything they want
i've gotten the covet vaccine so have i
i have to
so far ohio has spent more than 11
million dollars on traditional
advertising to promote vaccination
taking a relatively small amount of
money in the scheme of things
like five million dollars for incentives
in ohio and
offering it in this way that's drawn so
much attention has a real multiplier
effect
this has drawn attention not only in the
state of ohio
but nationally ohio governor mike dewine
has unlocked a secret
in the week leading up to the lottery
announcement ohio averaged 13
400 new vaccinations a day then a couple
days after we announced it we were
starting to see in our numbers
going up in the week following an
average of 26
500 ohioans were getting their first
shot each day
a number caveated by the fact that teens
aged 12 to 15 were newly eligible
for the vaccine but still the state
reported a 28
week-over-week increase in vaccination
rates among those 16 and older the
weekend after the announcement
incentives make sense for some people
they're likely to be
motivating for individuals who are say
young and healthy
though vaccination they're not opposed
to it but it's not really a priority for
them so offering something that
is a tangible benefit can help get them
there
sooner negy had initially planned to
wait to get her 12 and 14 year olds
their shots
with myself i felt a lot more
comfortable just going and getting the
vaccine with my kids i did kind of want
to see like
you know nothing popping up like crazy
uh side effects or anything like that
but after hearing about vaccination i
thought why not a free ride to college
sounds great
why wait i knew i was gonna probably do
it anyway so
um yeah i thought that would be awesome
so i just went ahead and got him
vaccinated
that said momentum from the campaign in
ohio may be slowing
in the week following the drawing of the
first winner the state's daily average
of new vaccinations was backed down to
about 11 000.
i think seeing the winners out there is
going to continue to
you know generate some excitement but if
it doesn't do anything else besides
what it's already done it's been worth
it one potential downside for states
offering big prizes
still looms as it appears increasingly
likely boosters will be needed to
maintain
protection from the virus we talk about
the spoonful of sugar helping the
medicine go down but if you can only get
people to take the medicine with the
sugar you have habituated them to that
we might
be creating a precedent now for
something that can be expensive
and potentially inefficient in the
future setting a precedent doesn't worry
governor dewine who's focused on getting
shots in arms now
ss state still lags behind the national
average not every decision we've made
has been right
but it's been based on you know the
best facts that we could gather and so
are we going to offer this in the future
i don't know but
you know we're going to continue to do
what it takes
to knock this virus down as she did with
her initial vaccination
naggy says she won't wait for an
incentive before getting a booster
yeah i definitely wouldn't expect it but
if you know if it happened
great happy correlation